how do you remain level-headed a human
because while fighting for those big
dreams and believing you can do big
things because I see the I see the
humanity in everyone I don't see titles
positions I don't see none of that
matters because look at this stage in my
life what I tell young people I've
probably been at every powerful table
there is right I've met kings and queens
I've been at G summits
all the people are the same
everybody is carrying around their fear
they are fighting to be seen and heard
I've seen the country and everybody is
fighting for the same thing we may not
believe in the same politics we may not
pray to the same God but in the end
we're just trying to live a decent life
raise our kids that's what I see when I
connect with people